Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P.
Here is a voicemail with a different
perspective on COVID at this point.
I don't know if this is serious or a satire.
Speaker 5: So as we begin the third year
of COVID, I realize that COVID can't be real.
This is just the new version of The Truman Show,
right? And eventually going to say
You're out, it was all just a TV show.
Thanks. You do a great job.
Speaker 1: Have a good day. I assume that
it's a satire. But The Truman Show, a fantastic
film starring Jim Carrey in which he doesn't know
that he has been raised in a television program
and the real world population is watching it.
And I mean, listen, I am open to the idea that
we're living in a simulation. I don't know that
COVID is that proof. I'll just leave it at that.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about Karl Rove saying, Hey, these
Republicans, they got to just go hard against the
Trump rioters. This is not something you want to
mess around with. We will talk about the ethical
and legal questions surrounding Sean Hannity and
his text messages related to the Trump riots.
And we will talk about, you know, I know it's
20 22. Maricopa County, Arizona, officials are
finally ready to say the 2020 election is over.
They seem ready to say we're not going to get
Arizona flipped from Joe Biden to Donald Trump.
They're accepting it now in January of 2022.
All of those stories and more on today's and show.
Unidentified: Sign up at join Pakman.com